while the machine learning world is
still very busy partying with diffusion
models there's a new Transformer model
on the Block released late this
September called whisper and instead of
being yet another Transformer text
generation model It's actually an
automatic speech recognition or speech
to text model there are many ways that
we can actually check out this model
it's fully open sourced for inference
and you can just download the model and
use it the team behind whisper is oh
I'm sorry there's got to be some sort of
technical difficulties going on here
there must be a mistake does that say
open AI
yeah
okay yeah it's an actually uh openish
model from open AI that you can just
download and use incredible so let's see
some quick examples of this model's
performance and then we'll jump into the
paper which actually has a surprising
amount of just general AI insights
Beyond just telling us more about the
model and project itself
I encourage you to at least try the
hugging face web app implementation if
you have any sort of mic available I
think theirs is actually running on the
CPU so inference time is about nine
seconds or something less I tried if you
have like a few seconds of audio on a
GPU you should be seeing something like
inference times of maybe 500
milliseconds to one or two seconds for
multiple seconds of audio also the
hugging phase implementation is using
the small model there's a variety of
model sizes so each of those is going to
have varying performance and in terms of
accuracy as well as inference speeds so
anyway let's check those out now here's
a simple example and implementation
using a sound sample that I have
recorded so just how good is this open
AI whisper there's a lot of background
noise in this recording I haven't turned
off my air conditioning to transcribe
this we can use the sample code from the
GitHub which again we have to respect
effect how exceptionally simple this all
is to use it was one line to install
everything and then I just a couple
lines of code essentially to get the
transcription
on first running you might find the time
it takes to run everything is a little
bit more than say 500 milliseconds but
this is mostly because the model has to
load onto the GPU and then all your
subsequent inferences will be much
faster for the purposes of testing these
models I've made a range of audio
samples with the exact same sentence
with just varying quality from that
Baseline decent quality example with
some basic background noise that you've
heard already all the way up to this one
so that's how good is this open AI
whisper there's a lot of background
noise
the way I made these is just by
recording the previous variant just out
from my speakers into my microphone each
time this this re-recording just sounds
worse and worse but the microphone was
like three feet from the speakers the
air conditioner is still running and
just yeah everything just slowly kind of
degrades over time I stopped at four
just because I feel like people at this
point at least myself would start
getting some if not many of the words
wrong so I didn't really see a point in
continuing that process to just complete
gibberish from here I wrote a quick
script to iterate through each of the
model sizes and then each of the audio
recording qualities to see both how
quick inference times can be between the
various model sizes and to get a very
kind of basic General look at how well
can they perform from decent quality to
very subpar quality data again this is
just like one sentence one sample
there's just a tiny little amount of
words compared to the entire data set of
possible words so this is obviously a
very very basic test but just a general
vague idea
found the results to be shocking on the
worst quality sample I found both medium
and large to do a pretty good job really
just confusing the have to versus the
have not turned off my air conditioning
and so on but the other stuff it
actually got quite right definitely very
impressive results and all models
perform inference faster than real time
at least on a 30 90 GPU obviously this
is going to vary depending on where you
run the models but even that tiny model
is pretty good if the quality of audio
is also pretty good too and both the
tiny and base models only require about
a gig in memory to run which is pretty
awesome and even the largest model so
far that's available is only 10 gigs of
memory which is very comfortable for
today's day and age
so let's check out the associated paper
which I find most interesting for it's
not just about the model but really
probably most of the gold nuggets in
here are just the more generic
implications and findings for machine
learning and AI models in general first
off the whisper model is what they're
calling weekly supervise which just
means it's trained on not perfect gold
standard training data it's data with
imperfect audio recordings and
background noise and and all of that
notably there is way more like orders of
magnitude more weak data than gold
standard quality data for audio training
and when it comes to speech to text I
would say the reality of using speech to
text is not gold standard many times
if not the majority of times I I'm I
don't really know but I all the times I
could think of where people are using
speech to text most of the time I think
it's from a poor microphone in a in a
phone or maybe elect I don't want to say
the name and Trigger people's but anyway
those devices
um so I and those are all going to be
very imperfect settings so you really do
want speech to text to work in an
imperfect setting I think that's the
most common scenario when you're using
speech to text now we have gold standard
uh training data that is about a
thousand hours and just a few years ago
the gold standard training data was only
about 50 hours so as time goes on we do
have a very quickly growing gold
standard data set and with enough time
and grad students this could eventually
be hundreds of thousands of hours and
maybe even millions of hours that said
the amount of audio available online
that isn't gold standard is always going
to outnumber the gold standard
audio quality right and Beyond this
there is a slight question as we will
get to in this paper do we really want
only gold standard data is this the
ideal for training especially with a
speech to text so the question is can we
use this data to make a good audio based
model and if so how might it compare to
the current state-of-the-art models in
this case that's state-of-the-art for
speech to text but there are many
questions and implications from the
findings here or you'll be very
comparable to findings in say some of
the latest image models
so the first Insight here is a current
issue with fine-tuning models especially
true with speech models I think it's
just very evident with speech models
um versus some of these other more you
know because like a speech model there
is a right and a very right and very
wrong answer whereas with
um typical like GPT generation models uh
there are many options that could have
been the case same thing with like image
generation models there are many images
that would match a prompt that you might
put in so it can be it can be tough to
validate uh you know validate those
models basically other than did it
produce grammatically correct output and
all that so the first Insight here is
that when you're fine-tuning these let's
say speech to text models you might have
an exceptionally robust model that can
differentiate between like phonemes and
different words and characters and do
that super well so
um with speech to text there are many
words that sound exactly the same right
but based on the context of of preceding
words we can
that's how we know what that next word
should be and so you might have a model
that's exceptionally well and then you
go and fine tune it on say a new speaker
and very quickly that model loses a lot
of its robustness and it's highly likely
to very quickly overfit to that new
speaker one tactic that I've personally
seen to handle for this situation is
from Nvidia and I don't know if they're
the ones that really made this up it's
just the first place that I had seen it
is basically you will fine-tune on new
data mixed in with original data this
might be original data that was held out
specifically for this purpose but even
though you're trying to fine-tune to
some new speaker you're kind of mixing
in the old data as well and this seems
to help with the overfitment to the fine
tuning new speaker openai here wonders
if similar gains in performance with
image models where where data sets are
going you know far beyond the highly
curated and perfected data sets like
that of imagenet to more like websites
like deviantART and such whether this
strategy can apply to Audio models as
well and again I think there's an
important differentiator here between
speech to text versus text to speech so
in text to speech I think it'll be
interesting to see can someone use this
like weekly supervised model to go from
text to speech because in text-to-speech
you really want that produced speech to
sound
amazing right you want it to sound as
high quality as possible whereas speech
to text you don't have the same problem
you're just trying to take speech and
get the correct words that were said so
I'm not I'm very curious to see if there
will be any
um any output so you you know maybe
maybe you primarily train the model on
you know uh not you know imperfect sound
quality data and then you fine tune it
on the gold standard maybe mixed it I
don't know I have no idea but just take
note that this this direction of
of using imperfect data I I feel like
can only go one way right with you know
dirty speech to text you can't really go
text to dirty speech in the training and
then expect in practice for that to
sound good anyway the training data set
itself for this model is 680 000 hours
of audio 117 000 of which cover 96 other
languages other than English and 125 000
hours are other language audio to
English text translations
uh which is interesting and cool to like
fold in those capabilities but also
fairly interesting that they're finding
that for large models and and also I
would argue with enough data uh there
seems to be no drawbacks and only gains
to doing things like supporting multiple
languages so doing the transcriptions
for multiple languages all in the same
model and doing different types of tasks
so multitasking uh all in the same model
so in this case we're transcribing for
many different languages but then we
also are capable of translating
many different languages historical
convention was to always keep things as
narrow as possible for success but with
larger models and arguably larger data
sets for those models we seem to be
finding that mixing tasks and training
data to support those tasks to add sort
of generalization and robustness as well
as we'll see later models with mixed
tasks and data to support them they they
tend to just simply perform
holistically better
even on those single narrow tasks than
models that were trained to just do
those narrow tasks
um so rather than maybe rather than
confusing the model by having multiple
tasks in multiple languages it seems as
though that it actually helps to do uh a
little more generalization
so even on say transcribing English
the models that were trained purely just
to transcribe English
did worse than the models that were on
the task of transcribing just English
then the models that were trained to
transcribe English translate uh other
languages and
um or rather transcribe English
transcribe other languages and then also
translate those other languages back to
English I'm probably going to mix up
translate and transcribe somewhere in
this video I apologize in advance
so for the data set and the training
data in General open AI did not curate
the data sets very much the audio
quality varies a ton the speakers
obviously vary a ton the main focus
seems to have been on making sure
transcript quality was good and
trustworthy so they're trying to remove
cases where they could detect where yet
another speech to text algorithm was
being used to generate the transcripts
somewhat ironically here I think this is
the type of issue that we're going to be
facing more and more as time goes on
especially for example with like image
based models so these models very
quickly with the influx of all these new
AI generated images uh there if we're
not careful going to be very quickly
training on themselves
and as that happens the quality and the
diversity and the I guess creativity of
those images is highly likely to just
devote evolve over time so I think we're
going to start seeing the rise of models
that can detect things like was this
transcript generated by an AI was this
image generated by an AI was this audio
generated by an AI and so on if not for
many other reasons but also for
continuing to train those AIS so it's a
quite the ironic problem to be having
to actually train this model the
training data was broken into segments
of 30 seconds in length so then later
when you're actually doing inference if
you have data that is longer than 30
seconds it's going to get chunked out
and then kind of built back together in
sections the model itself is an encoder
decoder Transformer and the tokenizer
for the text is a byte level byte pair
encoder same one that we've been seeing
now for quite some time the single model
does the entire job of detecting the
language detecting the target task like
translate or transcribe and so on to
control this Model Behavior of detecting
the language and do we want to translate
or transcribe they're actually just
using text tags like translate or
transcribe which is very interesting to
see for this sort of task I wonder if
we'll start to see this edition of tag
task types that's a hard one to say in
future GPT style models so uh what they
found here is that yes mixing in these
different tasks and stuff actually added
to robustness and generalization so will
future GPT models have these you know
intended task types besides just you
know generate text uh I think that'll be
very interesting and if they did what
would what would those tasks be because
it also is
seemingly questionable does the task
actually matter as long as it does the
task correctly
um does it matter which ones you throw
into the model or do you just want to
have some different tasks purely for
generalization's sake
um
I have no idea I look forward to seeing
uh if they do have task tags uh what
would they be you know and uh how would
that work and all that anyway it's very
interesting to think about uh as we go
forward
so here we have the pipeline
illustration for the model to give you
possibly a better understanding of how
the model functions but again I think
the biggest takeaway here is the
successful implementation of these
tokens that are denoting things like
what do we what do we want them the rest
of this generation essentially uh to be
doing do we want it to transcribe
translate all that and what language is
it all that stuff like it just because
that is the sequence that it has always
seen the fact that it can even just like
detect language this way is
uh very interesting so I'm not totally
shocked that this works but mixing
especially like translation into a model
that primarily just transcribes
is very curious that it works so well
as well as tossing in 96 other languages
other than just English
so the model sizes vary from 4 to 32
layers and 39 million to up to 1.5
billion parameters these are the models
that I tested earlier in the quality in
inference times section 3.3 is yet
another important insight into the sort
of generalization for AI models I think
the point here is that you've got
generalization when it comes to the
entire training data set that you've
used versus generalization to the actual
task itself
and this is where the in distribution
and out of distribution terms come from
and arguably an entire New Field of
research to get more models to be more
successful out of distribution on tasks
as well the point here being that models
trained on imagenet for example a highly
curated curated curated gold standard
type of data set May outperform humans
in various classification tasks on even
held out from training but yet still a
part of that imagenet data set so it
might have super human performance in
this case but then if you go and grab
random images from the internet as a
true out of distribution samples uh you
find that again for the same class
classification task humans tend to do
better and this is a open question but
this seems to be this notion of fitting
to this sort of kind of gold standard or
some other attribute to that data set
that as soon as you go to real world
application occasion suddenly that AI is
underperforming and this seems to be
plausibly why what I think open Ai and
probably others are proposing here is
that it's possible this is due to models
sort of overfitting to the data set
style or equality or other factors and
that possibly it's really just as simple
as being over fit to a sort of gold
standard and just simply not being able
to handle for noise and reality whereas
humans suddenly do a very better job
because humans have a more truly
generalized approach to solving the
problem of say image classification or
even speech to text for that matter one
thing I can also verify here is on page
8 where openai notes that nvidia's
speech to text outperforms on the Gold's
standard data sets so high quality data
sets but then underperforms when
compared to whisper on data sets with
more noise which I definitely agree with
and have experienced myself and I think
is exemplified at the beginning of this
video showing how much we can distort
the audio
and Whisper still performs at what I
would call superhuman level at minimum
it's super syntax level
it did get some words wrong but I
definitely would have gotten those words
wrong as well if I didn't know the
transcript already
and obvious question is what might
happen if we continue to increase the
model size the largest whisper is 1.5
billion parameters versus something like
gbd3 with 175 billion parameters I think
the main concern at the moment is that
too large of a model will be able to
overfit the data that is available we
can already see that English speech
recognition performance does not really
vary much from 768 million parameters to
1.5 billion so it's not really looking
like if we just increase the model size
that much is going to change there this
would begin to suggest at least to me
that a larger model might improve the
maybe multilingual speech recognition
and probably translation but it seems
like mainly it's going to come down to
data set size which I think we can see
already in table six and this is also
curious because there's actually way
less data for those tasks and yet it
seems like those continue to improve as
the model increases and again I start to
wonder like getting back to these tags
if you wanted to do uh text to speech
you use this you know weekly supervised
data set to get a good Baseline Audio
model and then maybe if you want to
produce audio maybe you have like a
clean audio tag and then on that clean
audio tag is only gold standard audio so
maybe you just haven't maybe you just
have an audio model that that can do
speech to text and I'm not sure if you
could you can't go the other way I don't
think anyway I'm like thinking these
things through life but I think like you
could possibly have at least a
text-to-speech model that could still do
the translation so you know maybe input
English text and then output you know
Spanish audio
um so I think you could still probably
have that and then and then to clean the
audio maybe you just have like a clean
audio tag or something like that and so
the question is would that continue
would that produce a better model
because based on what I'm reading in
this paper so far I think that logic
holds that you could still train that
Baseline model uh and then for the task
of clean Audio Only please you could
have us a much smaller subset of data
and that model should probably perform
better but I am curious what the audio
sound actually clean anyway I don't know
so finally open AI does go that step
further with questions about model size
and multi-task performance where they do
note that for small models the
incorporation of multiple tasks and
multiple languages does seem to cause
degradation when compared to English
only so again models that are trained to
just transcribe English the smaller
models that just transcribe English
these do benefit from being having their
task be very narrow so only training on
English transcriptions only doing
English transcriptions the smaller
models tend to do well but interestingly
and most importantly for the larger
experiments The Joint models the ones
that do transcriptions and translations
and all that they outperform the English
only models this is quite the insight
and I think an overall shift and Trend
that we're going to be seeing for years
to come with data quality quantity model
size and model scope sometimes model
scope purely for the purposes of General
generalization and nothing more it in
the end I think we're going to wind up
with far more out of distribution
generalized AI from this and then also
more powerful narrow AI
due to this seemingly interesting
behavior of somehow doing better when
you just toss more tasks and more types
of data at the model and again I'm
curious I'm curious to hear what you
guys think if you've gone through this
paper and really thought about this or
maybe you know a little bit more about
mixing these like tasks in what do you
think about text to speech that uses
this weekly supervised data to just have
this like General text-to-speech and
then maybe one of those tag tasks
because in this case the thing that
they're verifying and validating is how
does the English translation work rather
than they did not unless I'd have to go
back and check uh did they
did they compare a model that did just
let's say translation
did the translation model also do better
or would it have been better off being a
narrow AI because I had way less data
that I don't know and I wonder uh I
wonder because in my example of doing
speech to text and then you know having
a you know gold standard tag so you
produce the or text-to-speech rather uh
having a gold standard tag would that
make clean audio then because that's
like super important for at least text
to speech
um yeah I don't know interesting
interesting questions anyways thank you
to openai for sharing your model and
your insights and all of that with us
it's very cool to see from open Ai and
I'll uh at least be using whisper I'm
pretty sure for all of my current speech
to text needs and then possibly
translation there's a lot of really cool
apps that can be made from these models
and again these are pretty powerful yet
pretty lightweight models
um so yeah really cool that's all for
now I will see you guys in another video